we're here in Central Park which is one
of the world's great urban spaces open
squares had existed in cities for
millennia but they were primarily places
of Commerce not Sylvan refuges from the
strife of city life after all nature was
seen as something dangerous looming
menacingly beyond city walls it was only
in the 19th century when Romantic poets
like Keats and Wordsworth began to
penetrate a church
city is filled up with migrants from
farms who presumably missed a little bit
of grass and a few flowers the downsized
extreme density the fetid water the
unclean air the mountains of human
refuge made the idea of a Sylvan retreat
even more appealing by the mid 19th
century New York City's 1811 grit plan
gave little space for open parks only
the parade now Madison Square Park was
marked on the plan as being a clearly
visible urban park william cullen bryant
the editor of the New York Evening Post
took up the call for a larger Park here
in New York Bryant had been born in a
log cabin in Massachusetts but he came
to New York and enjoyed huge success as
the editor of the New York Evening Post
he was joined by Andrew Jackson downing
the founding father of landscape
architecture in America and together
they waged a campaign for a greener
cleaner New York their campaign brings
forth legislation in 1853 which sets
aside 700 acres for a park it also
establishes a Park Commission so much of
the great 19th century infrastructure in
New York was built by state appointed
Commission's not local government the
Croton Aqueduct estate Commission the
Erie Canal Estate Commission Central
Park Estate Commission and so the Park
Commission held a contest to cop with
the best plan for a park that would
enrich the lives of ordinary New Yorkers
it was won by two young men Calvert veau
and Frederick Law Olmsted beau had been
a partner in Downing's office Olmsted
had no experience in landscape
architecture he'd been a journalist
whose writings on the antebellum south
still contains some of the most vivid
descriptions of that slave economy
together they designed a green sward
masterpiece a People's Park that would
be open to all they eschewed the
marble arches that would bar the
entrance for the poor instead they have
simple easy entry ways that welcoming
anyone and they filled their park with
marvels like this pond which in the
summer is filled with boats that bob up
and down there are 36 bridges designed
by Calvert Bois himself throughout the
park there's a sheep's meadow where
sheep themselves gambled on the green
until 1934 there's a castle the
Belvedere that rises out of the mists
it's not even short on the attempts to
impress civic values it's filled with
statues of 19th century icons like Sir
Walter Scott and William Shakespeare of
course the park does create challenges
most importantly maintenance and
programming all of this green space when
all of this humanity can create a mess
the park can easily get rundown so over
the course of the late 19th and early
20th centuries when Tammany Hall had
little use for a park that abutted the
buildings that were occupied by their
wealthy political enemies the park
decayed it was only in 1933 when the
reforming Mayor Fiorello LaGuardia was
elected that the park acquired a new
life he appointed the redoubtable Robert
Moses who took the park firmly in hand
Moses is responsible for much of the
park as indeed he is responsible for
much of New York City's infrastructure
but he's particularly associated with
the zoo
Central Park had had animals since 1859
when private donors started menagerie
but it was really Moses who gave the zoo
its modern form a form that is delighted
New York's children for generations
I particularly treasured the Delacorte
clock tower that was only built in 1965
where the animals danced around to the
sound of the chimes the park again
suffered to decay in the 60s and 70s
when New York's crime got out of control
as a kid I always felt that this was a
place of danger at least apart from the
prime visiting hours on weekends when I
had to commute through the park during a
transit strike
I talked loudly to myself in the hopes
that apparent insanity would deter
would-be mothers the famed jogger case
is a particularly notorious example of
crime in Central Park
of course the park did become safe again
as the city became safe and now
thousands of joggers go through the park
enjoying its pleasures programming is
the other challenge this great urban
space calls for humanity to use it well
perhaps the most important entrepreneur
in that regard was Joseph Papp who in
the 1960s began his Shakespeare in the
Park which brought some of the world's
greatest actors right here to the park
to performances that were free I have
fond memories of watching Kevin Kline
and Henry v their 40 years ago this park
is an urban marvel and it is a tribute
both to the vision of VAW and Olmsted
and to the value of having green space
within the city it is also a tribute to
the generosity of New York's land fists
who have helped to improve and maintain
the park over the years there are
legitimate public policy questions about
Central Park he's it too large would it
be better if it were carved into more
smaller parks and spread more evenly
throughout the city but while you can
ask those questions there's no doubt
that this park is an absolute treasure
for New York and a model of what truly
beautiful urban space can be
you